there is a young woman who has gone
viral for making a little Tik Tock video
saying that she works a lot and she
doesn't have enough time and money to
really enjoy anything in her life
outside of work and conservatives are
attacking her and saying she's got to
pull herself up by her bootstraps and
stiff up her lip and all the rest of it
but that's not exactly my take on what
she is
saying why is it that
I have to work 40 hours a week just so I
can have a place to live 40 hours a week
makes me $2,000 a month and my rent is
$660 so I work 40 hours a week so I can
have a two-bedroom apartment and an
extra $300 a month like it doesn't cover
my phone internet food you know so not
only do I and not have any extra money
but just working makes me so
exhausted that I don't have time
either like I get off work at
5:30 come home and I'm just so
tired I'm so tired that
like anything that I need to do outside
of work I then just push off to like the
weekend and I'm like I'm just too re
tired to do this after work I'll wait
until Saturday so then I end up with so
much to do on the weekend that ends up
having to be split into 2 days so I have
to do stuff on both Saturday and
Sunday so then I don't get a day off I
don't get a day to relax I don't get to
decompress so it is really like working
7 days a week
constantly and I don't want to do that
anymore right like I don't care how poor
and miserable I would have to be but I
literally can't have a place to live
without this you know
like I don't know what to do I'm not I'm
not made for this I don't have the money
time or energy to enjoy my life outside
of work and I don't know what to do
about it anymore you know I'm so
tired I know the conservatives are
making fun of her because they're saying
a listen here snowflake you know quit
your belly aching 40 hours that's not so
hard when I was a kid I used to walk
uphill both ways in the snow and I'd
work 400 hours a week and I never once
grumbled about it you snowflake but
that's not really my take on it I
totally sympathize with her I empathize
with her you know I remember when I was
younger and uh wasn't quite sure where
my career is going and hadn't quite
settled down into my personal life and
that was before we hit this this period
of massive inflation where people can't
afford anything when my wife goes to the
grocery store the eggs cost like $50
each at this point you know and they're
college educated organic pasture raised
you know properly pedigreed eggs but
still all all the groceries are like
that and the rents have gone through the
roof and what this woman is saying is I
I have trouble affording my rent I have
trouble affording my groceries I I'm
working 40 hours a week at a job that is
not satisfying to me and then I got to
do my chores and errands on the weekends
but I don't have anyone with whom to
split the bills and I don't have anyone
to take care of some of the chores and I
I'm suffering from a crisis not just of
money and not just of work but a crisis
of meaning that's what she's really
saying saying that's what that last line
at the end there is is I wasn't made for
this and that's true what what she's
talking about is living in a a world
long after industrialization long after
the breakdown of Civic Society a world
long after the breakdown of community
where she feels isolated and she's
living alone and she's carrying that
burden herself and and the jobs have
become so specialized and seemingly
meaningless that she doesn't see any
point in them at all doesn't really see
the fruits of her effort and she gets to
the end of it and she says I don't even
have Leisure and I'm not sure frankly I
think what's implied by our present
state of society is I don't even know
what I would do if I did have leisure
time and I I don't feel that I was made
for this and I think she's totally right
we we were not made for this we're made
to be part of a community we're made to
have a sense of our purpose we're made
to start families and have children and
were made to uh not just be
automatons but I don't even know know
what this woman's particular job is
but work increasingly over the last 150
years has turned human beings into cogs
in a machine and that's a problem it's a
problem especially when the the other
aspects of life that give you meaning
religion family community leisure
activities all go away and so you're
just left say what the hell am I even
doing I totally totally sympathize right
now go to goodranchers.com use code
nolles February is the month of love
baby and everyone knows that they love
bacon which means that you are going to
love getting free bacon from good
ranchers when you subscribe to any of
their 100% American Meat boxes they will
add one and a half pounds of Applewood
smoked bacon to your order for free for
a year good ranchers sources all of
their meat from local farms and ranches
in the us meaning you can trust every
bite it's not just about taste it's
about the experiences and memories
associated with it whether it's the
mouthwatering smell through the kitchen
on a Sunday or or the joy of sharing a
plate of bacon wrapped appetizers with
friends good ranchers has a way of
creating moments that linger in people's
hearts and taste buds I've been on the
road for a week and it's been fine I've
had a good time I was in LA I was in
Santa Barbara but the the one thing that
I really miss apart from My Wife and
Kids glad I got that in there is my good
ranchers I don't get to have the good
ranchers when I'm on the road so fall in
love with beef chicken seafood and
especially bacon All Over Again by
subscribing at goodranchers.com use code
NES kW to claim 40 bucks in free bacon
the offer is not available on their site
it is an exclusive offer to our
listeners that is goodranchers.com use
cod nolles k
wle for the best bacon in the USA
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
turning from a woman I think justly
complaining or understandably
complaining to a woman who is not
understandably complaining we turn now
to Sunny host from The View who insists
that most Americans are
racist there are absolutely racist
people in this country it is not the
vast majority of people in this country
and I feel like well FBI director said
white supremacy is the biggest threat to
our country today well that still
doesn't mean that that's the vast
majority of people I just don't believe
that in my dayto day life that the
people that you're encountering Harbor
racist viewpoints I do think that this
division that we're Crea you look like
me you would believe differently but you
know what listen the woman the woman so
but just to just to understand saying do
we think the vast majority of Americans
are racist that's what I'm trying to
Hope me understand I think that there is
a significant portion um that are racist
and you can't dismiss my lived
experience and I never would say I would
never when I say that there are a lot of
racist in this country I just
experienced my son walking down the
beach being called the nword several
times in Florida so don't you can't say
I believe that the vast majority of
people aren't
racist that's fair there are 300 million
people in this country I would never
minimize your lived experience any more
than I would mine as an
AR the majority of Americans are racist
even though there's no um and by racist
of course Sunny hustin does not mean
people attacking whites for the color of
their skin by law by culture no no no it
can't be that because you can't be
racist against white people no no it's
got to be racism against black people
and to a much lesser degree every other
race and this is not borne out by any
statistics this is not born out by any
particular trends that anyone can point
to so of course Sunny hus has to say
Well it no the proof is my personal
anecdotes and you ought to believe me
though Sunny htin is not really all that
credible as uh Nick fond dearo points
out as this clip went viral uh she's
been known to spread the these sorts of
hoaxes before but we hear this kind of
stuff all the time no no no look
whatever the statistics show whatever
you have experienced in your own
personal life just trust us America is
deeply profoundly racist there's no
answer to
it I don't think that line Works quite
as well anymore I don't but it it is the
consistent uh cheat of left-wing
Scoundrels it is the once you've run out
of every other AR argument once you've
run out of every other um tactic in
politics then you just cut to saying
well my opponents are terrible racists
and that's that and if you dare ask me
for evidence oh boy then you're a racist
too how dare you question my lived
experience with these pesky little
things like facts and statistics and uh
history that's always what it will get
to and you're going to hear a lot more
of it in this election cycle because
there's not very much for the Democrats
to brag about the economy and shambles
were on the brink of World War II we
don't have any borders effectively
you've got illegal aliens being let off
the hook for additional crimes that they
commit in this country they've got
nothing and so TR truly the only
argument they're going to have they're
going to try to pretend that the economy
is better than it is and then after that
they're going to say well you're a
racist aren't you that's that's the
evidence it's proof positive that all
the other issues for the Democrats are
not going very well man what a great
clip that was now hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time